قال رئيس الوزراء العراقي محمد شياع
السوداني ان الاتفاق الذي ابرم خلال زياره
الامين العام للمجلس الاعلى للامن القومي
الايراني علي شمخان الى بغداد يتضمن
الاتفاق على ضبط الحدود المشتركه بين
البلدين ومنعه اقامه معسكرات لقوى مسلحه
يشكل وجودها تهديدا لطهرانه واضاف سوداني
خلال مقابله مع الجزيره لبرنامج المقابله
والذي يقدمه علي الظفيري انه يامل ان
يساهم هذا الاتفاق في استقرار المنطقه
فقدنا سلسله اجتماعات واجراءات على مستوى
مجلس الامن الوطني على مستوى اللجان
المشتركه بيننا وبين ايران بناء على
زيارته الى طهران قبل ثلاثه اشهر وصلنا
الى هذا الاتفاق يوم تم توقيعه والذي يلزم
بمسك الحدود تسليم المطلوبين ومنع
المعسكرات وباقي التفاصيل نامل ان يكون
هذا الاتفاق يعني عامل
استقرار وامن للحدود والحكومه الاتحاديه
وحكومه اقليم كردستان معنيه بتنفيذ هذا
الاتفاق
واشار رئيس الوزراء العراقي لان العلاقه
بين ايران وواشنطن وبعض دول الخليج لا يجب
ان تنعكس على الداخل العراقي واكد رفضه ان
اعتداء على اي دوله جاره انطلاقا من
الاراضي العراقيه
اعطاني تفويض بانه في حال تكليفك بالحكومه
انت وحكومتك مخول ان تؤدي هذا الدور
وتخرجون باتفاق واضح المعالم ايش نحتاج من
قوات التحالف الدولي مثلا نحتاج منه
التدريب نتفق هذا البرنامج التدريبي سنه
سنتين ثلاثه نحتاج من عندهم تبادل
المعلومات اذا اتفقنا على هذه الرؤيه
وصارت باتفاق واضح ومعلن ينتهي بعد دور
السلاح عند اي جهه
ينتهي متى نصل مرحله نزع السلاح بشكل كامل
لانه احنا بدانا هذا واحد من واجبات
الحكومه اللي بديناها من خلال نقاشات في
داخل مجلس الامن الوطني بديله نخوض هذا
الحوار مع التحالف الدوليه وهناك افكار
سوف تنضج الى ان تفضي الى اتفاق عندها لن
يكون هناك مبرر لوجود اي سلاح ثانوي غير
سلاح الدوله